Good morning John! I am in sunny Florida.
It's raining pretty hard right now.
I mean, not really THAT hard.
It is beautiful here. I am loving the, the-
wetness actually.
It's very dry in Montana.
My skin breaks out. My nose gets all crackly
I like it! I want to be moist!
I maybe don't want to be this moist though
I may have come out later and film this at a different time
There's a dog... coming to pee
Quick before it gets all rainy!
Oh no!
Okay that was bad timing.
[Thundering]
Okay yeah. No. It's. Okay. Let's go.
I'm back. It's tomorrow.
It was a long storm and now it's very bright back there
But it felt like I committed to this spot, you know?
I'm in Florida for my in-laws' 50th wedding anniversary
Then I tweeted, "
Okay, I'm in Florida on vacation and I need to make a video
That is fun and quick and not stressful because I need to get back in there [splash] and celebrate.
Hello Big Fish!
So I asked for questions, and I got this from one from Amanda who asks,
"Have you watched the Orin butt wiggle video yet today?"
I haven't. I did watch it yesterday.
But look... I also have the real thing.
Scott Manly says, "What is the expected velocity of an unladen swallow?"
Is it African or European? Scott you didn't say.
Come on!
Grace Helbig said, "Dance."
And I will remind you that I said want not
stressful questions to answer.
Dance, is one, not question.
Two: It's so many people watching. You crazed? Jeez.
What's under your feet right now?
I'm sitting down, and I don't want to touch my camera because it is an extremely precarious set up right now
But here under my feet. Look!
Nothing. Air. Air on both sides.
This is how I sit by the way.
I am very flexible in one, one way, and it's this way.
Hey.
Hi.
Hey. [Chuckling]
Is this good video? I have no idea.
What should I embroider on my jacket?
Fancy... dingo.
Seems like a good one.
Smell of gasoline. Yes or no?
I mean yes.
Show us your favorite dance move right now.
Come on people!
Who put the ram in the "Rama Lama Ding Dong"?
I bet this is something I can Google.
"Rama Lama Ding Dong"
What's a person who wrote a song's name?
Songwriter?
George Jones Jr.
He put the ram in "Rama Lama Ding Dong."
Somebody should shake his hand...
He's dead.
[Awkward laughing]
He died in 2- 2008.
Wow, they originally called that the "Lama Rama Ding Dong" on the cover of the album
That must have been a bad day when he got it delivered.
He was like, "Come on, you guys!"
I've been workin' so hard, on this, my legacy.
And you're like "Blama Rama" - No! It's Rama Lama!
Yanny or Laurel?
Look. I'm a Yanny.
And I think that it's done with and it's over.
But I'm a Yanny. It happened.
And then I showed Katherine, and she's a Laurel
And she... thought... that I was lying to her... about Yanny.
But it's real, okay?
Yanny's are real!
Please- oh hello, Blue-jay! Aww.
What do you think of the word moi-
I used the word moist earlier in this video yesterday when I was making- making it.
What I would like to say to you is, "I think it is word that useful and we should think of it in its usefulness."
But I also really like it.
That was my baby screaming.
Why did he scream?
Cause he was like, "No, dad. Don't talk about the word moist."
Elizabeth asks, "Would eating a carnivorous plant be considered vegan?"
Of course it would.
There's. Wait. WAIT.
No. You're right.
Shoot.
I mean does it come up that often.
Do we need to have rules for everything?
Nate asks, "What is your favorite non-serious dance move?"
Raphaelia asks, "Show us your favorite dance move right now!"
Echo asks, "Your best dance moves."
Paulina says, "Recreate Orin's dance."
You guys really want me to dance.
So here's the situation: my baby has a bunch of different dance moves.
So I'm going to do one of them for you.
I'm going to do my currently, -my favorite of Orin's dance moves is
I call it finger guns.
I'm gonna have to get far enough away from the camera to do it.
[music with vocalizations begins] Okay. Here I am doing fingerguns.
There it is. That's Hank Green doing finger guns.
Now you've all seen it.
I hope that you appreciate it. Hank Green doing finger guns.
John, I will see you on Tuesday.